let me ask you for advice what what
would you say to Young Folks
wherever they come from so in high
school and college they're thinking of
how to live
a life have a career they can they can
be proud of and especially if they're
struggling especially if they're at a
low Point like you are when you came
here
a travel travel is one of the biggest
things in the world that I would ask
people to kind of go out to uh see how
other people live don't go there with
your own preconceived notions they're
trying to make people act like you act
like go out there and travel and
actually experience the world
it doesn't have to be another country uh
going from Tennessee to Seattle you know
it's a pretty interesting uh change of
uh a scenery who's better knife fighting
just kidding you don't have to answer
that uh that's fantastic but uh the uh
traveling is one and knowing how other
people live uh is one aspect of it that
would tell people uh it's risky it's
dangerous but that is part of the
journey is one of the things I would ask
people uh young people to kind of like
consider
service is essential and it should be at
the basis of all of our Lives service
start there start with service
in any industry you're going to go start
your own restaurant you have to work in
the kitchen for service if you're going
to be a part a productive member of this
country service and I'm not talking just
about the military because the military
it's it's a process and it's a lifestyle
and it's a thing for some people out
there it's not even a choice for other
people if they want an education and I
get that community service of any kind
is an essential thing the ability to go
out there and interact with the people
that you would normally not interact
with the homeless population that you
know that is in this country uh the the
older population that uh in Mexico or
our old die in our homes you know uh you
know but here you send them off
somewhere else to die which is an
interesting weird Detachment that I've
seen in the US as far as how the elders
are are cast aside uh if I can say
anything to young people is to start
figuring out a life of service and
that's gonna that's gonna expose you to
a bunch of experiences to a bunch of
people out there that you might not
regularly kind of meet and see and
realities
education
is out there
it is expensive but I've sat through a
bunch of really expensive classes that
I've managed to see on YouTube and
learned a lot from them
uh so education is out there but it
doesn't have to be as expensive as they
as they make it it's all about the
individual and what he does without
education
the dream is free and the hustle is sold
separately is something else I watch
somewhere in uh online but the ability
to take uh take information process it
and use it uh we're expecting everything
to be safe processed and given to us in
a platter and taking that and digesting
and thinking that's going to make us
somebody that's going to be productive
or valuable in society
that's up to us
the U.S talks a lot about freedoms but
doesn't talk a lot about
responsibilities I think that's a big
part of you know take responsibility for
[ __ ] like I came here without anything
and the first thing I thought was
I have a responsibility for the people
that I've
worked with and the people that are
going through the same problem the same
problems than I am how can I figure out
a way to help
yeah the Dark Side of thinking a lot
about freedom is thinking too
individualistically meaning thinking
about me how to optimize my situation
forgetting that the deepest growth
you can do as an individual is by taking
care of others by helping others by
being of service by being useful to your
community locally and then hopefully
also at scale and that's how you grow
and that's responsibility of like
helping those around you there's an
isolationist aspect to culture now yeah
it's like we we're separate there's a
there's almost like a spiritual or
cultural amputation in a way where
you know when when I was a kid the house
where all the bikes outside of it that
that was where all the kids were hanging
out
and now everybody's on their phone you
know in the separate houses I chatting
on whatever
um
there's a Detachment to there that's a
it's a weird aspect to it and also the
the the aspect of I'm I need to be safe
I can't be offended don't hurt me say
spaces this is my right this is my this
is my right this is my reality you need
to respect it
yeah respect is earned and my when where
I come from respect is earned
um there's freedoms but there's
dangerous freedoms those are those any
freedom you have in Mexico is a
dangerous freedom in a way you know you
can drive home drunk in Mexico you can
if you bribe a cop on your way there and
if you don't die or crash into somebody
else that's a dangerous aspect of
Freedom uh but there's a responsibility
to all of it
it is a twisted responsibility and a
twisted way kind of talk about and
describe it but I think the the aspect
of people screaming for Freedom up here
or their rights or their privilege
without the responsibility you know you
know what are you doing for your
community you know what you're
complaining about this what are you
doing about it you know another thing
I've noticed in traveling around it's
scary is the whole people people getting
shouted down or canceled because of what
the express or say
some of the creepiest experiences I've
had in the US has been through
universities or so just seeing young
people that have an opinion that is
completely outside of reality you know
um people telling me how things are in
Mexico because they learned it through a
college course yes and seeing sons of
immigrants
criticizing me because of my opinion of
Mexico or what I have to say about it
and you know if you want to encounter
the worst enemy of a Mexican is usually
a second third generation Mexican up
here that uh shouts you down for what
you're saying I mean in general
entitlement all those kinds of things I
I some of that comes with just being
young in general but yes humility
uh humility at a societal scale would
would benefit significantly especially
the young so I I would say some of the
service that you're speaking to is comes
with being humbled yeah and that that is
one of the best things you can do as a
young person whilst maintaining the
dream and the ambition humble yourself
to the reality of the world yeah one
small example a micro example of this uh
my kid
there was a homeless guy uh she was out
with some with family members his homely
guy homeless guy showed up he was
erratic mentally mentally Disturbed
previous scene she was upset
there was a little bit of trauma there
so like oh now all homeless people are
bad
so with her she does art pieces
sometimes for me and helps me make
designs for the clothing brand that I
have
and we take some of that money and we
buy socks and underwear you know
and I sometimes I have them in the car
sometimes I drive around see somebody
need something and I give it to her and
says you helped me earn this money
that's going to help these people so you
should just give them these and she's
like yeah
and like ah thank you she's like hey
it's cool uh
she used to roll up the window really
quick now she doesn't
they cease to be scary yeah because now
some of them have names now some of them
know her name you know when when they
when she crosses by there so she's
there's contact there she's more
connected than I am in some of these
places now you know she has Friends in
Low Places
and in high places that comes later I
guess
but she is learning about service she's
learning about not every not not
everybody out there is an enemy or bad
or scary
she's learning about service
and she's uh basically learning that
lesson that I got from my mom long ago
you know nobody's against you they're
for themselves don't take anything
personal
and if you're not doing something for
other people while you're working then
you're not doing anything
so when you were young you were pretty
sure you're gonna die before you're 30.
yeah what's your relationship with death
today do you think about your mortality
are you afraid of it I'm not afraid of
it if anything I'm afraid of uh
uh meaningless
death or at least a mean a meaningless
uh walk towards it
I'm afraid of losing the use of my legs
I guess I'm afraid of uh not being able
to go out there and do things anymore
I'm afraid that I'm not physically
capable of doing the job that I used to
do
uh so if anything I'm afraid of
Stillness you know something I always
quote a lot in my writing Stillness is
death
so you always want to be challenging
yourself moving growing like you're
traveling so you get all these
experiences and filling your life with
all these experiences and if it ends
when it ends you're ready for it yeah
I'm not afraid of the end the ending is
important in all things
first time I got a promotion I got two
silver coins handed to me
there's a silver coin and this is
another silver coin and the
is that I'll give you the the other one
when your job ends
yeah
it depends on you if you wanted to have
it over your eyes or in your pocket
right and uh the lesson there is that uh
you know this job you're getting it's
pretty cool and you're going to be in
charge of all these people and it's
pretty important but it's gonna end
so you always have to the ending is
important in all things
um if we don't keep that in mind then if
you think we're Immortal and nothing's
going to end I think that's a there's an
atrophy a spiritual atrophy in that
for the sake of spiritual flourishing
this conversation too must come to an
end so I think a beautiful way to end it
and I'm a huge fan of yours thank you
for
being a man with a life well lived and
for talking with me today is an honor
man it was an awesome conversation I
thank you for having me on